[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans par
l'om dos le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat avec à mes côtés
petit bonhomme bon gentil bonjour auriol
et cette semaine notre invité est
sylvain maillard bonjour député la
république en marche de paris merci
d'être avec nous et dans l'actualité
parlementaire cette semaine il ya
d'abord le lancement du grand débat
national par le président de la
république
emmanuel macron étaient dans leur mardi
devant 653 maire normand en parallèle
lors des questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée le premier ministre
déclarait que le gouvernement était prêt
à faire vivre ce débat au parlement
les passeports diplomatiques de benalla
au coeur de nouvelles auditions au sénat
la commission denquête interrogé le
directeur de cabinet de l'elysée et les
ministres de l'intérieur et des affaires
étrangères christophe castaner et jean
yves le drian placé en garde à vue cette
semaine alexandre benalla devra de
nouveau s'expliquer lundi devant les
sénateurs
nous reviendrons aussi sur ce rapport
très attendu présenté cette semaine à
l'assemblée celui la mission
d'information sur la révision des lois
de bioéthique
il se dit favorable à l'ouverture de la
pma pour tout élève de nombreux autres
interdit et on commence avec une
question quelle place pour le parlement
dans le grand débat national
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une lettre aux français d déplacement
dans l'eure et dans le lot 7 heures de
discussion avec les maires emmanuel
macron donc lancé cette semaine le grand
débat national destiné à répondre à la
crise des gilet jaune le président a
fixé des limites
pas de remise en cause de la ligne
économique notamment de la réforme de
liesse f
mais il a ouvert le jeu sur d'autres
sujets par exemple à la limitation de la
vitesse à 80 km/heure et dans le même
temps à l'assemblée nationale lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
mardi le premier ministre edouard
philippe a répondu au député sur la
place du parlement dans ce futur débat
écoutez sa réponse je veux dire qu'il ne
me paraîtrait pas absurde et qu il me
semblerait même légitime que à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle on puisse
débattre
reconnaissez avec moi monsieur le député
qu'il y aurait quelque chose de curieux
à ce que le débat serait organisé
partout en france sauf à l'intérieur de
cet herbicide et donc il appartiendra
aux parlementaires ou plus exactement
aux formations politiques de déterminer
les modalités de ce débat mais bien
entendu nous y sommes prêts nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire et c'est d'ailleurs
le sens de la remarque avait formulé
président la république puisqu'il appelé
l'ensemble des assemblées politiques à
se saisir de ce débat pas simplement
celle ci l'assemblée nationale pas
simplement le sénat par les deux seules
assemblées parlementaires politique mais
l'ensemble des assemblées de notre pays
sylvain maillard pour vous quelle classe
doivent avoir le parlement et les
parlementaires dans ce débat nous nous
invitons tous les citoyens le président
de la république a invité tous les
citoyens à se saisir de ce moment
important un moment inédit de que sera
que qu'est le grand débat pardon est
donc évidemment les parlementaires ont
toute leur place
ils ont toute leur place d'abord pour
discuter au sein du parlement et c'est
vrai le premier ministre l'a très bien
dit d'ailleurs ce sera en fonction des
modalités que nous allons arrêter groupe
par groupe pour voir comment nous
pouvons faire vivre au sein du parlement
physiquement ce débat mais aussi les
parlementaires sur le terrain parce que
dans ce grand débat évidemment souvent
les mères sont en première ligne pour
organiser dans leurs mairies les débats
s'ils le souhaitent mais c'est aussi aux
parlementaires d'être d'abord aller
coûte je crois qu'il est important que
les parlementaires
soit dans les salles le plus possible
pour écouter pour entendre pas pour
animer mais pour être vraiment dans l'
écoute de nos citoyens c'est un moment
fort et le parlementaire a toute sa
place le député comme le sénateur a
toute sa place dans les différentes
grands débats qui vont s'organiser sur
l'ensemble du territoire
et puis je crois aussi dans certains
territoires peut-être y aura des
difficultés d'organisation peut être des
mères ne souhaiteront pas le faire
peut-être il peut arriver des problèmes
techniques d'organisation tout
simplement de légitimité je crois que le
député doit le député comme le sénateur
pardon doit absolument à ce moment-là
venir pour faire en sorte que le débat
puisse sur tous les territoires est
reconduit donc le parlementaire doit
d'être plutôt en retrait mais écoutez
force de proposition ensuite de
synthétiser et l'organiser lahoud lors
qu'il y aura des difficultés alors le
groupe la république en marche aussi les
at-il son son rôle à jouer dans ce débat
est ce que vous ferez des propositions
par exemple vous personnellement ce
qu'on ferait des propositions au cours
de ce débat bien sûr non seulement le
groupe la république en marche va faire
des propositions
ça c'est très clair nous travaillons
dessus mais chaque parlementaire peut
être amené ce que nous sommes citoyens
un manteau à faire des propositions oui
je ferai des propositions sur le travail
ce que doit être le travail sur la
rupture conventionnelle par exemple je
suis en train de travailler sur dessus
sur la rupture conventionnelle et
l'évolution que je pense de l'arabe
la rupture conventionnelle mais aussi
sur le travail la valeur travail le fait
que je pense qu'on ne doit pas payer
pour aller travailler et donc sur des
choses assez concrète sur l'abonnement
alors moi je suis député parisien
franciliens et on a des abonnements sur
une carte navigo
pourquoi le salarié doit payer la moitié
de cette carte navigo est ce que c'est
normal
est ce qu'il est normal que ce canteleu
le son patron souhaite le payer et ce
n'est pas possible c'est un avantage en
nature de payer la totalité de la carte
navigo est ce qu'on doit payer en france
à leur accueil pour travailler moi je
pense que non donc ce sera une de mes
propositions alors on voit dans ce débat
une demande de démocratie participative
notamment à travers leur hic le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne est ce
que pour vous cette démocratie
participative va affaiblir la démocratie
représentative et donc les
parlementaires moi la question ne se
pose pas comme ça elle se pose comment
faire pour que notre république soient
plus vivante que notre démocratie soit
plus vivante que que le citoyen se sente
plus entendus et qu'il puisse participer
à la vie démocratique
le gd ya quelques quelques minutes avec
des enfants de ma circonscription et je
leur disais j'espère que dans quelques
années vous serez député-maire enfin
vous participerez profondément à la vie
citoyenne
moi je pense que c'est essentiel et trop
de nos concitoyens pensent qu'ils en
sont exclus donc tout ce qui va avancer
vers je dirais l'expression d'une
volonté de fer communauté et d'apporter
des idées me semble intéressant après il
ya vraiment des modes et des vraies
difficultés sur la modalité du rite
comme nous la preuve nous la présenter
je crois qu'il faut faire attention
parfois une bonne idée parfois une bonne
idée peut se transformer en inverse moi
j'ai pas envie de qu'on est tous les
dimanches des votes sur pour ou contre
lille et j'ai pour ou contre la peine de
mort et nous savons très bien que un
rique très largement diffusés sans sans
garde-fou risquerait de devenir des
référendum pour ou contre simpliste tous
les dimanches donc il faut des
garde-fous mais qui est une expression
plus important de nos concitoyens ça j'y
suis favorable à l'or le président du
sénat a présenté jeudi ses voeux devant
la presse parlementaire l'occasion pour
gérard larcher de parler de ce grand
débat et de défendre l'utilité du
bicamérisme et du sénat mais l'occasion
aussi de lancer quelques piques au chef
de l'état
jérôme ramel il n'avait rien dit depuis
la publication de la lettre d' emmanuel
macron où le chef de l'état interroge
les français sur le rôle du sénat à une
possible réforme
mais pour sa conférence de presse de
rentrée gérard larcher a contre attaqué
déplorant d'abord la forme vrai vous
préciser que le président de la
république ne m'avait même pas prévenu
de sa lettre dit même que le parlement
allait être questionné les deux hommes
se sont vus lundi en tête à tête et
gérard larcher a été clair sur son refus
de réformer la chambre haute par
référendum
j'ai aussi rappelé au président de la
république l'a dit qu'aucune révision
constitutionnelle ne se fera sur le
strict respect des dispositions prévues
par la loi fondamentale
qu'on se le dise ces lits sur le grand
débat national gérard larcher salle une
initiative qui fait passer du rond-point
la table ronde sans toutefois cacher ses
réserves
je me suis prononcé pour le grand débat
j'ai pas dupe non plus il faut être
prudent faut être vigilant attentif à
toute tentative d'instrumentalisation
il faudra aussi être exigeants sur la
suite que l'exécutif proposera de donner
à cette consultation
enfin le président du sénat a salué un
retour du chef de l'état vers les mers
en rappelant qu'il exhorte depuis des
mois à entendre les territoires et ses
premiers représentants
et comme souvent le président du sénat a
conclu par une main tendue
je crois que la situation nous amène à
la nécessité sur un certain nombre de
sujets de travailler ensemble travailler
ensemble pour écouter et essayer de dire
ensemble bien commun dire le bien commun
ça doit être notre rôle un franc parler
avec des lignes rouges toujours bien
dressé sans fermer la porte au dialogue
gérard larcher a finalement fait du
gérard larcher rappelant au président de
la république qu'il avait aussi besoin
du sénat pour sortir de cette crise
sylvain maillard vous avez entendu un le
président du sénat dire qu'il n'avait
pas été prévenu du contenu de sa tête
alors qu'il est question du parlement du
sénat est ce que pour vous c'est une
erreur une maladresse de la part des
manuellement
je n'ai pas à commenter je n'en sais
rien je ne fais pas partie ni du sénat
ni de l'elysée donc je n'en sais rien là
dessus en tout cas ce que je crois
importe quel mal ronge doivent renouer
avec les territoires avec les élus
locaux gérard marché et le représentant
de l'onu les territoires c'est bien leur
est dû le prévenir bien bien sûr mais
peut probablement il ya de toute façon
besoin de plus d'explications et
peut-être enfin jeu honnêtement je n'ai
pas le détail de ce qui s'est passé en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que il
me semble important que l'on puisse on
sur les ronds-points qu'est ce qu'on a
dit on a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas rester
dans un système où on avait l'impression
que les parlementaires que la clarée et
la démocratie représentative ne vous ne
fonctionnait pas entre autres on a
entendu beaucoup de deux plaintes contre
les députés sur notre un autre un devis
supposée sur notre organisation mais
aussi sur les sénateurs et que la place
du sénat moi me semblent importantes à
définir est-ce que nous guérissons dans
le même système avec deux chambres
bicamérisme pourquoi pas mais nous nos
citoyens pensent que probablement il n'y
a pas suffisamment en tout cas de leur
point de vue de différence entre une
chambre et une autre moi je crois qu'il
faut profondément réformer un système
je pense que ça c'est le nez aux députés
que je suis je vois le temps que nous
prenons à étudier les textes nous sommes
dans nos 21e siècle ça doit aller
beaucoup plus vite
il faut que des mesures s'incarne
beaucoup plus rapidement et je crois que
notre organisation avec des textes qui
font ce qu'on appelle la navette d'une
chambre à l'autre prennent énormément de
temps ça veut pas dire que la valeur du
sénat doit être annulée bien entendu
qu'ils enrichissent nos textes et ça
c'est important mais probablement dans
notre fonctionnement il faut une réforme
donc moi j'invite sur les différentes
chambres à réfléchir sur comment faire
pour que ce soit plus efficace plus
constructif et que nous ne soyons pas
dans un système qui a été inventée conçu
il ya maintenant plusieurs dizaines
d'années et qui parfois peut paraître un
peu obsolète au regard de nos
concitoyens ça fait longtemps que ça
allait on va en revenir à notre deuxième
thème cette semaine retour de la sphère
benalla au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suite aux informations sur les
passeports diplomatiques de l'ancien
chargé de mission de l'elysée la
commission d' enquête sur l' affaire
pénale a repris ses auditions mercredi
patrick sauze à le directeur de cabinet
des manuels macro christophe castaner et
jean yves le drian ont répondu aux
questions des sénateurs avec à la clé de
nouvelles révélations quentin calme et à
plusieurs reprises patrick strzoda se
montre agacé et par moments même le
directeur de cabinet lâche sa colère
contre alexandre benalla le signe d'un
changement de ton l'elysée dénonce
désormais publiquement le comportement
de l'ancien chargé de mission depuis
décembre on sait qu'ils disposaient de
deux passeports diplomatiques des
passeports utilisés une vingtaine de
fois selon patrick strzoda entre le mois
d'août et le mois de décembre
plus grave encore alexandre benalla
aurait obtenu un de ces passeports grâce
à un faux document ce benalla adressée
au ministère de l'intérieur une note
dactylographié a en tête du chef de
cabine et une notes non signées de façon
manuscrite
tantôt on a dû ce document bien
évidemment on a demandé au chef de
cabinet si c'est lui qui avait adressé
ce document au ministère de l'intérieur
et il n'est pas l'auteur de cette note
des auditions qui révèle aussi des
failles dans l'organisation du ministère
de l'intérieur
hier christophe castaner le reconnaît il
est impossible techniquement d'empêcher
alexandre benalla d'utiliser ces
passeports diplomatiques en l'espèce
pour les passeports diplomatiques qui en
plus ne sont pas des passeports
biométriques et qui n'ont pas le même
niveau d'information il n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui de dire on interdit
autre dysfonctionnement au ministère des
affaires étrangères cette fois quand
alexandre bonnet là se rend au tchad les
5 et 6 décembre
l'ambassadeur français n'en fait pas
mention ministre al
j'ai interrogé le 26 décembre
notre ambassadeur sur ce sujet il m'a
fait savoir qu'il était informé de ce
déplacement et qu'il n'avait pas
considéré qu'il fallait en faire rapport
je lui ai fait savoir que c'était
regrettable il a reconnu c'était une
erreur
une journée riche en révélations avec
désormais une forte attente sur la suite
des auditions
car alex honnold benalla et le prochain
convoqué lundi au sénat quelques jours
seulement après le déclenchement d'une
nouvelle garde à vue dans ce dossier des
passeports et du faux à l'elysée c'est
sa manière est ce que vous avez été
surpris par ces révélations
oui surpris parce que évidemment je
pense comme l'ensemble des sénateurs
l'ensemble des français on découvre au
fur et à mesure l'étendue des dégâts
li très clairement des dégâts d'abord ça
va nous interroger nous concrètement sur
notre organisation
ce qu'a dit christophe castaner sur les
passeports diplomatiques c'est aussi une
une évolution que nous devons absolument
organiser dans l'état il n'est pas
possible de pour ne pas pouvoir
interdire des passeports diplomatiques
une fois qu'on vous a attribué on ne
peut pas techniquement
à l'heure actuelle les annuler ça c'est
pas possible parce que il ya sûrement le
passeport de monsieur benalla en tout
cas celui dont on parle il y en a
sûrement d'autres avec probablement
d'autres dans d'autres majorités la
majorité précédente qui ont encore
probablement des passeports
diplomatiques je le dis avec des
réserves tout en me disant que
probablement et donc je crois qu'il faut
aussi réformer ce système là de
distribution de passeports diplomatiques
non pas dans l'attribution et dans le
fait que quand ils ne sont plus adaptés
à la mission qui est tout à fait le cas
ils doivent être automatiquement arrêtés
et donc arrêté techniquement c'est assez
facile à faire sauf qu'il faut produire
il faut faire la puce est inséré la
en un passeport diplomatique
des choses comme ça qui sont des choses
techniques assez simple mais qu'il faut
mettre en place non pas qu'on se
retrouve dans des situations pareilles
alexandre benalla qui le menti en
déclarant lors de sa première audition
au sénat avoir laissé ces fameux
passeport à l'elysée si oui doit-il être
poursuivie pour parjure
s'il a menti ça il va être
redditionnelle lundi s'il a menti oui il
ya parjure très clairement puisque sinon
à ce moment là une commission
parlementaire si on peut dire n'importe
quoi
n'a plus de n'a plus de raison d'être
puisque c'est justement l'idée de scie
ne vous dit pas la vérité on vous
poursuivra pour parjure qui force qui
fait émerger la vérité dans une
commission parlementaire
donc oui je pense que c'est important
mais moi je crois beaucoup dans la
jussie je pense que au delà des
commissions parlementaires
et il ya une commission parlementaire du
de l'assemblée nationale il y en a une à
l'heure actuelle du sénat moi je pense
que la vérité émergera avant tout de la
justice et donc je fais confiance à la
justice pour dire le droit et pour dire
ce qui est nous révéler ce qui vraiment
a eu lieu ce qui s'est passé mais aussi
les dysfonctionnements pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus mais finalement vous
dites que la commission bancaire du
sénat elle a eu raison de persister
sans elle pas de nouvelles révélations
les sénateurs sont dans leur rôle
d'estimé eux s'il souhaite qu'on
continue et 7,7 cette commission
denquête moi je pense que c'est à la
justice de se saisir
je pense que c'est à la justice de dire
le droit je pense que c'est pas aux aux
députés ce n'est pas aux sénateurs mais
ils sont dans leur droit et en aucun cas
je vais m'y opposer vous parliez des
dégâts est ce que les dégâts y sont
aussi pour emmanuel macron est-ce que
benalla ça va être le sparadrap du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron les dégâts
ils sont pour tout le monde les dégâts y
sont pour la république
les dégâts sont oui notre majorité c'est
un c'est une vraie difficulté très
clairement mais je crois qu'il faut
affronter les difficultés fait partie
aussi de la vie d'hommes et de femmes
d'affronter les difficultés c'est une
difficulté mais on en ressortira plus
fort si on affronte et qu'on connaît
pleinement la la réalité des choses pour
pouvoir améliorer que ça ne se
reproduise plus je vous parlais du
passeport diplomatique
ça ça fait partie d'une d'une évolution
évidente on attribue un passeport
diplomatique ou un passeport de service
quand on n'est plus en service ou qu'on
ait pu attributaires de de ce passeport
est pas ça doit se désactiver tout
simplement aller on en vient à ce
rapport sur la bioéthique dévoilé cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinq mois de travaux plus de 60
auditions la mission d'information sur
la révision de la loi bioéthique a donc
rendu ses conclusions mercredi son
rapport prend position sur un sujet de
phares à l'extension de la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes feu vert à cette mesure au nom de
l'égalité entre les femmes et opposition
en revanche à la légalisation de la gpa
en france a résumé signé mathieu des
moulins la pma pour toutes les femmes
homosexuelles ou hétérosexuelles en
couple ou célibataire
c'est ce que propose le rapport
parlementaire de la mission
d'information sur la révision des lois
bioéthiques jusqu alors la fécondation
in vitro ou le don de sperme était
réservé aux seuls couples hétérosexuels
en cas d'infertilité ou de maladies
graves
le rapporteur la république en marche
jean louis touraine se dit également
favorable au remboursement de la pma par
la sécurité sociale dans les mêmes
conditions que les couples hétérosexuels
il souhaite aussi la levée de l'anonymat
des donneurs de sperme sous réserve
d'accord préalable
le rapport propose également de lever un
tabou en autorisant la procréation post
mortem que ce soit par insémination ou
par transfert d'embryon mois ci une
femme a le droit à une femme seule ou
une femme en couple a le droit
déjà maintenant d'adopter enfants et
demain en plus de faire des enfants avec
une pma utilisez donc le spermatozoïde
d'un donneur qui vient de l'autre bout
de la france
comment n'aura-t-elle pas le droit
d'utiliser le sperme de son propre mari
défunt on ne peut pas lui interdire cela
ce serait déraisonnable
d'autres sujets sensibles comme lotto
conservation d'ovocytes ou la
facilitation de recherche sur l'embryon
figurent également dans le rapport pas
question en revanche de donner son feu
vert à la gpa la gestation pour autrui
qui implique le recours à une mère
porteuse
le rapporteur propose cependant de
faciliter la reconnaissance de la
filiation
pour les enfants nés de gpa pratiqués à
l'étranger
nous n'acceptons pas qu'ils aient des
enfants bâtards dans notre pays au 21e
siècle il n'y a pas des enfants
légitimes enfants bâtards que les
enfants sonné de pma -avec parents
hétéros ou
mots avec une femme seule qui soit n'est
de gpa à l'étranger
il n'y a aucune raison pour que enfin
n'est pas la plénitude de leurs droits
et de leur filiation
toutes ces propositions devraient
inspirer le futur projet de loi de
bioéthique qui sera normalement débattu
à l'assemblée nationale au début de
l'été sylvain maier questions simples
sur la forme est compliquée sur le fond
êtes vous favorable à la pma pour toutes
les femmes
oui je suis favorable à la pma pour
toutes les femmes
c'était une promesse de campagne du
candidat emmanuel macron que nous avons
porté ses dunes quand une promesse de
campagne que j'ai porté aussi pendant
les législatives
et donc oui je suis favorable et je suis
favorable aussi au remboursement de
cette pma parce que je crois qu'il ya
une égalité tout simple donc oui pour la
pma oui pour le remboursement par contre
pour la gpa je reste sur les positions
précède que nous avons porté au moment
de l'élection c'est à dire non
contrôleurs pour la gpa je suis contre
la gpa mais je pense à l'intérêt de
l'enfant
l'intérêt de l'enfant pour moi c'est la
priorité je crois que l'enfant né de gpa
à l'étranger doit avoir la pleine
la pleine reconnaissance de l'état
français c'est un enfant français et
donc il doit voir l'ensemble des droits
c'est ce qui est parquée dans ce rapport
et j'y suis particulièrement favorable
pour pardon je déborde mais sûr par
contre là l'utilisation de
spermatozoïdes d'un mari d'un défunt je
suis plus réservé dessus je l'attends
aussi des auditions sûrs à des auditions
des discussions dessus parce que ça me
semble peut-être parfois plus compliqué
éthiquement peut-être plus difficile
mais ça nous aurons un débat
parlementaire et c'est aussi du débat
parlementaire que naît parfois souvent
même la vérité ou ou la conviction la
conviction du député justement vous
faites part de votre besoin
d'information le premier sera annoncé
qu'un séminaire sera organisé au
parlement dans les prochaines semaines
pour pour informer justement les députés
sur ces questions l'objectif est
d'arriver à un climat plus apaisé que
lors des débats sur le mariage pour tous
oui clairement c'est ça l'idée d'abord
le travail de jean louis touraine et de
l'ensemble de cette de cette commission
c'était vraiment très en amont
d'associer l'ensemble des parlements
r moi j'ai assisté à certaines auditions
pas tout parce que sinon il ya eu
énormément d'audition mais pour qu'au
fur et à mesure nous puissions avoir cet
intime conviction qu'ils se forgent quel
que soit le groupe d'ailleurs parce que
les différences ne sont plus en fonction
des groupes politiques elles sont
vraiment d'une intime conviction
je crois que le travail est bien fait au
parlement je crois ou senna d'ailleurs
c'est peu dans les mêmes termes que ça
va se se dérouler il me semble important
que nous arrivions à une décision
apaiser le plus apaisé possible on a
connu des discussions très difficiles
sur le mariage pour tous qui rendront
les conséquences pour faire en sorte
qu'une une décision soit mûrement
réfléchie et qu'elles soient
accompagnées dans l'ensemble du pays
ça me semble important alors l'une de
vos collègues et a eu des propos qui ont
fait débat au sein même de votre groupe
la députée la république en marche de
l'oise année un style qui a déclaré que
l'extension de la pma et je cite cette
absence de gens dans le mot parent
favorise l'éclosion d'écoles coraniques
est ce que ce sont des propos qui vous
ont choqué moi je ne veux pas commenter
en permanence les propos d'avant je
connais pas le contexte de ces de son
nom de son propos moi ce que je crois
qu'il est important on connaît les
convictions dania style on l'est on les
connaît depuis longtemps c'est pas s'est
pas caché quand elle a été candidate à
la république en marche nous savions ce
les origines d'où elles venaient son
passé et je crois qu'elle fait partie
d'une réflexion d'enrichissement de
notre majorité est d'alerter d'entre
elles a toute sa place à mon avis aux
fins en tout cas c'est ma conviction
intime qui a toute sa place
par contre elle a des positions qui ne
sont pas majoritaires loin s'en faut
sur certains points sur entre autres sur
ce que vous venez de dire je pense que
elle doit pouvoir s'exprimer mais très
clairement la majorité des députés
la république en marche veulent si ce
n'est l'unanimité veulent la paix m à
l'extension d'un pma et le remboursement
c'est une promesse de campagne que nous
avons tous porté sur laquelle nous nous
avons été élus il me semble important de
la réaliser un mot sylvain mayer pour
finir cette émission sur une autre loi
votée cette semaine une loi d'actualité
puisque l'assemblée et le sénat ont
définitivement à 2
c'est un texte permettant au
gouvernement de préparer le scénario
d'un brésil dur un cap il ya plus que
jamais possible après le rejet par le
parlement britannique de l'accord
soutenu par theresa may sylvain maier la
france est elle prête avec ce ce texte à
faire face à nos deals difficile à la
position des français comme l'ensemble
des européens parce que nous sommes
tributaires d'une d'une hystérie c'est
l'hystérie qui a lieu à l'heure actuelle
en grande bretagne ils ne savent pas à
quelques jours du break site où ils vont
c'est quand même c'est quand même dingue
de se retrouver dans une situation
pareille
donc nous moi je fais partie de la
commission spéciale sur l'étude des
ordonnances sur le break site
on a dit une solution simple nous on
s'occupe de nous des français est de
faire en sorte que quelle que soit la
solution qui soit acquis qui émerge du
côté britannique que ce soit un break si
dur un accord qui aient ratifié ou bien
même un revote un vote référendaire à
nouveau en grande bretagne nous serions
prêts à faire face en france parce que
nous sommes obligés de récré en tout cas
de prévoir de recréer une frontière
c'est terriblement difficile nous avons
pu voir le nombre de détails sur
lesquels il faut travailler très
rapidement pour trouver des solutions
je crois que nous avons donnés en tout
cas l'ensemble des pouvoirs législatifs
au gouvernement pour y faire face nous
serons prêts en tout cas et on
arrestations d'hier et venir dans les
semaines à venir merci beaucoup c'est
avec nous mais rien ne trouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]